père du premier bébé éprouvette jacques
testart scientifique sera magny les
hameaux jeudi soir à la maison de
l'environnement à 20h30 l'invitation de
collectifs autre monde il présentera son
dernier livre à qui profitent les ogm et
citoyen engagé il considère que la
science et la faire de chacun la
recherche doit se faire de manière
démocratique et nous l'avons rencontré
chez lui dans les hauts-de-seine un
reportage julie rocha soares bonjour
jacques testart vous êtes directeur de
recherche honoraire à l'inserm est aussi
le père scientifique d'amandine premier
bébé éprouvette de france elle fêtera
d'ailleurs ses 31 ans le 24 février vous
êtes fier
je suis pas mécontent
qu'est ce que ça vous au pas vous savez
c'est
bon ça il ya eu tellement de bébé après
qui les bébés et les artisans qui ont
permis de les fabriquer ont les mêmes
mérite donc maintenant il ya tellement
mon aussi qui fait ça dans les hôpitaux
dans les cliniques donc c'est banaliser
alors c'est vrai que le premier mais
c'était surtout un événement médiatique
le souvenir que j'en ai c'est surtout
des hordes de journalistes
bon une agression pourrait dire d'accord
outre sa date importante quand même dans
votre carrière de biologistes vous êtes
invité jeudi à une conférence du
collectif autre monde elle s'intitule
techno sciences et démocratie qu'est ce
que la techno science alors la
technoscience et un mot un peu ingrat
peut-être qu'il n'aurait pas dû médecin
sur la fiche parce que ça fait peur aux
gens mais c'est un mot inventé par des
philosophes il ya une quarantaine
d'années des philosophes des sciences
pour désigner la nouvelle façon de faire
la science traditionnellement la science
était surtout la recherche de
connaissances donc la soif de l'homme de
connaître enfin de la poésie qu'on
pourrait dire et puis aujourd'hui c'est
essentiellement de la mise au point de
techniques pour l'innovation compétitive
on entend parler sans arrêt de
croissance et de compétition c'est pas
avec des idées que ça se fait c'est avec
des machines des molécules des brevets
donc la science est devenu aujourd'hui
une activité qui est complètement
inscrits dans l'économie mondiale et ça
le donne des caractères particuliers à
la fois au métier de chercheur à la
nature des recherches qui sont faites à
cette compétition effrénée qui a entre
les équipes entre les pays bref je vois
pas pour moi c'est un mois un peu
péjoratif techno science mais ça existe
et on est bien obligé d'en tenir compte
parce que aujourd'hui par exemple pour
faire de la recherche scientifique il
faut avoir l'aval d'un industriel pas
seulement parce qu'il va donner un peu
de sou laboratoire mais parce qu'il va
aussi donner une caution pour nos pères
pour les scientifiques qui décide des
attributions c'est très important qu'un
industriel apporte une caution parce que
l'industriel est quelqu'un davies et qui
va pas mettre ses sous dans un panier
percé donc c'était une espèce de
garantie mais ça veut dire que les
sujets sont choisis finalement par ces
gens là quoi et pour le coup vous vous
souhaiteriez une science démocratique
qui inclut le citoyen dans quelle mesure
est ce faisable
c'est eu un problème de décision
politique mais c'est une science
démocratique ça veut dire qu'il y aurait
toujours la recherche de connaissances
qui n'existent quasiment plus il
faudrait au contraire mettre davantage
de crédit et pour la partie qu'on
appelle la recherche appliquée donc de
l'innovation de tout ça ce serait aux
citoyens de décider qu'est-ce qu'ils
veulent qu'on mette au point parce que
finalement ça se fait à partir de
concepts qu'on a déjà et on peut mettre
au point en priorité telle ou telle
machine tel ou tel traitement contre tel
maladif il ya plein de choses on peut
pas tout faire donc il faut faire des
choix actuellement ils sont faits par
les gens de la finance en peut dire non
c'est pas normal donc il faudrait que
les choix soient faits par des citoyens
par le biais de conventions c'est ça
alors nous effectivement à l'association
sciences citoyennes on a lancé
l' idée assez précise de conventions de
citoyens c'est un aménagement de ce
qu'on appelle les conférences de
citoyens mais c'est très très flou donc
là on a un protocole précis qui devrait
on espère un jour faire l'objet d'une
loi et par lequel une quinzaine de
personnes tirées au sort serait formé
complètement c'est à dire de façon
contradictoire on leur donnerait tous
les points de vue pendant assez
longtemps pour caser soit parfaitement
éclairé et qu'elle puisse donner un avis
qui servirait aux politiques à prendre
les grandes décisions vous avez un
exemple de débats dans l'actualité dans
lequel les citoyens pourraient être
interrogés je pense notamment à
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
pour les homosexuels oui bah pas raison
il ya énormément de points des points
assez précis lors par exemple celui là
oui les homosexuels dans la procréation
assistée effectivement c'est un sujet
qui peut être débattu par des citoyens
bien informés et qu'ils n'ont pas
d'intérêt particulier c'est à dire qu'on
ne mettrait pas d'homosexuels dans ce
set a semblé involontairement mais ont
tiré au sort des gens et il pourrait
donc discuté tous à entendre des
homosexuels puisque c'est une parole qui
portent quand même un point de vue qui
doit absolument être entendu entendre
des philosophes des psychologues des
juristes des anthropologues ont toutes
sortes de gens qu'on voit d'habitude
dans les comités d'éthique mais qui vont
pas trop vers l'est des comités de
citoyens ça n'existe pas vraiment vous
êtes quand même auteur d'articles et
d'ouvragés de vulgarisation scientifique
le vous vous définissez comme critique
de science votre dernier ouveillan
ouvrage vient de paraître aux éditions
du cnrs vous interrogez à qui profitent
les ogm rapidement quelles sont vos
revendications
c'est un peu ce que je viens de dire
d'abord les ogm il faudrait demander aux
gens s'ils en veulent un contour des ogm
là on n'a pas le temps de détailler mais
on parle des plantes parce qu'il ya
d'autres ogm qui sont utiles mais on
parle des plantes les pgm les plantes
génétiquement modifiées qui ne servent à
rien pour les consommateurs c'est ça
qu'il faut quand même répétée et qu'on
est en train de nous imposer parce que
les multinationales veulent absolument
nous imposer ses plans cela donc elle
présente certains risques bon il ya eu
la sphère séralini a montré que des rats
pouvait avoir des tumeurs il ya d'autres
publications scientifiques qui montrent
que c'est possible si sûr mais de toute
façon un s'ils n'ont aucun avantage on
n'a pas à prendre le moindre risque et
les ris et pas seulement les risques
sanitaires c'est des risques pour
l'économie agricole pour la vie des
paysans pour la biodiversité dont c'est
quelque chose qui peut chambouler
complètement tout le territoire et ricol
toute l'alimentation mondiale alors que
ça n'a aucun avantage il faut vraiment
que les lobbys soit très puissante on
arrive à nous imposer cette chose vous
parlais justement d'alimentation va
terminer sur cette question d'actualité
comment réagissez-vous au scandale de la
viande chevaline dans les plats surgelés
indiqué pur boeuf est une filière à
revoir c'est pour seulement les filières
à revoir c'est tout le système qui est à
revoir c'est comment on s'est d'abord
les pénalités qu'est ce que risquent les
gens qui font ça ils vont avoir une
amende non s'il avait 20 ans de prison
je pense que y réfléchir est un peu
avant donc je crois qu'il y aille je
veux dire quelqu'un qui veulent du pain
dans une boulangerie est davantage
condamné que ces types là qu'on commence
vraiment fait une fraude délibérée pour
gagner beaucoup d'argent ça c'est pas
normal donc il ya un problème de justice
sociale qu'on retrouve là et je crois
pas que les gens soient parfaits donc il
faut quand des gens ont des
responsabilités ce qu'elle cas des gens
qui nous livre l'alimentation il faut
qu'ils soient obligés de respecter des
normes et pour ça il faut leur faire un
peu peur
merci jacques testart de nous avoir
reçus je rappelle que l'on peut vous
retrouver ce jeudi à la maison de
l'environnement de magny les hameaux
pour une conférence débat à 20h30 sur le
thème techno sciences et démocratie
conférence donc de jacques testart
demain jeudi julie vous le disais à
20h30 le détail sur le site internet de
la maison de l'environnement à
magny-les-hameaux toujours autour de
cette thématique de la nourriture des
ogm et autres polémiques autour de la
viande de cheval nous sommes allés
aujourd'hui vous demander si vous aviez
peur de ceux qui se trouvaient dans vos
assiettes vos réponses oui je fais
attention à ce qui est dans mon assiette
absolument la raison de tout ce qui se
passe au niveau alimentaire de
de l'élevage de voile à des produits
chimiques etc non
mais parce que j'achète des produits
simples
des produits naturels et je les
transforme en moi même eu pas trop pas
trop parce que je pense qu'il faut
rester modérée monte après la viande de
cheval c'est une viande comme une autre
donc
après bon c'est le mensonge sur
l'étiquetage voilà je suis assistante
maternelle et je cuisine tout pour les
enfants parce que j'ai peur de ce qu'il
ya dans les aciers dans dans les plats
cuisinés qu'on ne nous dise pas tout non
parce que si on a peur de tout on fait
plus rien après voilà donc il faut pas
trop fumé patron mangez pas trop boire
pas trop de sel pas trop de sucre pas
trop de gras voilà je suis attention de
bien pas suivre ces recommandations